juste est ce que est ce que est ce qu'il
ya une virginie dans le public vers
tunis énergie virginie virginie à vichy
c'est qu'ils avaient érigées alors je
vous explique pas ce que ce soit je le
vannes oc les deux gagnants pour la
voyez ce milieu plein de gens qui se
sont installés pour venir avec moi en
laponie et il règne toujours c'est un
truc de ouf qui a été sélectionné et le
hasard a fait qu'elle était dans le
public ce soir on devait l'armée et aux
sétois virginie virginie faut que tu
fasses ta valise parce que je lis soit
tu pars avec fulham
vous savez travailler les connais pas ce
contact nous a téléphoné hier parce
qu'on a sélectionné plein de gens y
avait je crois qu'en fait on avait
quatre idées sélectionnées et parmi ces
quatre navettes ou qui devait rester
vous devez faire un dessin et de nadine
aujourd'hui donc compter sur le plateau
et parmi ces quatre ans fait et je fais
partie des deux camps et qui sait rien
ou un garçon qui était ex-aequo
on a appris tout à l'heure mais voilà tu
pars avec mes genoux ces bons à rien du
tout chaud merci merci à toi le salon
c'est aux couleurs samedi 7
portrait on va merci à tous tout et les
gros bisous mais quand je reçois
[Applaudissements]